vsauce kevin here with two games
if you play game a you are guaranteed
to lose if you play game b
you are guaranteed to lose
but if you alternate back and forth
between
playing game a and playing game b you
are
guaranteed to win how
how can two losing games combine
into one winning one is it just some
cheap
game hack or something more and does
this mean
that grandma was wrong and it's actually
possible for
two wrongs to make a right welcome to
perrondo's paradox physicist juan
parondo who created this paradox
demonstrated it by flipping a
biased coin a coin that instead of
having 50 50 odds of landing on heads or
tails
has 49 and a half 50 and a half odds
so slightly unfair biased odds
and that's not going to work for us
because precision biased coins that
look like normal coins are likely
impossible
or as statisticians andrew gellman and
deborah nolan wrote
in a 2002 paper you can load or die
but you can't bias a coin so instead i
made a series of games using
three roulette wheels with a total of
114 spaces
and one markov chain because
penguins seriously this paradox can be
visualized using a penguin
slide toy the same mechanism that moves
these penguins to the top allows us to
turn
two losing games into our own money
printing machine
this is this is really loud i'll explain
how later but for now let's actually
talk about
our games okay game a works like this
it's a game of chance
in which your odds of winning are
slightly lower than your odds
of losing the american roulette wheel
has 38 spaces
18 red and 18 black and
these two green zeros the rules of game
a
are that you can only bet on red or
black either way our odds of winning are
18 out of 38
or 47.3 so a little less than
50 50. that means the house edge is
5.2 which will round down to
5 because of that 5 losing edge
theoretically every time we bet a dollar
on this game
we'll lose about 5 cents if we start
with 100 bucks and keep
playing this game we'll be totally broke
after about
2 000 spins in the long run when we play
game a we're guaranteed to lose
come on red
[Applause]
since definitely losing sounds terrible
let's give game b a shot
before we do that you may want to add up
all the numbers on a roulette wheel and
just
tell me these some in the comments okay
b is composed of
two games of chance each with different
odds you'll still bet
one dollar but the wheel that you play
depends on how much money you have left
we'll call these
b1 and b2 you'll play b1
only if your total money is a multiple
of
m and let's say that m equals three so
if you're left over money is a multiple
of three
like 93 or 81 or
66 then you have to play we'll be
one if your bankroll balance is not a
multiple of three then
you'll play wheel b2 here's
the catch with b1 you're only allowed to
make what's called a
corner bet choosing an intersection of
four
numbers so you'll win one dollar if the
ball lands on any one
of those four so like a corner bet of 26
27 29 and 30. a corner bet means your
odds of winning
are just 4 out of 38 or about
10 so when you play b1 you're going to
lose
90 percent of the time losing isn't
guaranteed but
you're gonna lose a lot more often than
not game b1
is a pretty bad game for the player
don't worry though
b2 is much better you get to choose a
combination of winning spaces
red or black and odd
or even so if you choose red and evens
you'd win every time the ball lands on a
red space
or an even space even if it's a black
even space
the two green spaces are also winners
for you
on b2 this allows b2's odds to shift
significantly in your favor with 18 reds
and 9 black
evens plus the two greens giving you a
total of 29
chances to win out of 38 possible spaces
and that my friends is 76
the good news is that since there are
more possible money counts that aren't
multiples of
three than there are you'll be playing
the much friendlier
b2 a lot more than the nearly impossible
b1 so that means most of the time with
game b
you'll be winning right no here's the
thing
b1 is a loss 90 of the time
and since you'll also lose roughly one
out of every four times you play
b2 overall you're guaranteed to lose if
you just
play the b games game b is actually a
markov chain a stochastic process that
takes a situation like ours
different states with varying
probabilities and generates a loss by
b1's disproportionate effect on
our fortunes let me explain the key is
that even though there are only
three possible states of our money
balance a multiple of three
like 90 or 93 or two possible states in
between multiples of three
like 91 and 92 our probabilities of
playing the bad
b-1 game versus the better b-2 game
aren't a simple one-third and two-thirds
what's surprising is that a markov chain
analysis
and if you want to learn more about
markov chains i'll link you to a course
on those in the description
shows that our probability of playing
the bad
b-1 game is actually closer to
40 percent and the winning edge that the
good b2 game gives us
just isn't enough to make up for the
terrible b1
all of that is to say that game a is a
simple guaranteed loser and game b is a
kinda
complex guaranteed loser and
this is getting dreadful so let's bring
back our penguins
and lighten the mood our
flightless bird friends will help us
visualize how we leverage
two negatives to create a positive in a
2000 paper titled perrondo's paradoxical
games
and the discrete brownian ratchet
derrick abbott parando and others
described a process
known as the flashing brownian ratchet
as an analogy for how
the paradox works basically directed
motion is achieved by alternating
between a sawtooth and a flat
potential i'll show you these
penguins clearly reach the top of the
slide even though
they themselves aren't moving because
they're being carried back and forth
between
two downward slope sawtooth shapes and a
flat shape
these shapes slope downward and this
shape here
sorry penguin is flat yet the penguins
climb
to the top by alternating between them
okay that's loud sorry penguins wee the
end excuse me
a second happy feet think of game a as
our flat shape
because the odds of winning game a are
close to 50
50 with a slight bias toward losing
think of game b
as our sawtooth shape because the odds
are much steeper
in game b1 and much better in game b2
creating a distinct asymmetry
look at that but instead of moving
plastic penguins uphill
by alternating between game a and game b
we the player are carried upward by our
combination
of losing games into
winning to put it another way we can get
really simple and mathy about
this back to the north pole with you say
you start with 100
and each time you play game a you lose
one dollar that's it done that's just
how
game a works in this simplified scenario
you're a loser with no hope of winning
and if you played game a 100 times your
financial trajectory goes downward until
you're broke there are two strains of
game b
if the amount of money you have left is
an even number like
82 bucks then you win three dollars
if it's an odd number say you're down to
71 bucks then you
lose five bucks if you only played game
b
you'd be broke even faster than if you
just
auto lost game a at least with game a
you'd get to play it
100 times both game a and game b
are clearly 100 losing
games but when you switch back and forth
you can make them
profitable check it out play game a and
you're down to
99 bucks that's an odd number so you
don't
want to play game b or else you'd lose
another five bucks
instead you play game a again and just
lose another dollar now you're at 98
bucks
when you switch to game b you win three
dollars and
suddenly you're up to 101 dollars
lose game a to get to 100 win game b
to get to 103. you could repeat a cycle
of a b
switching to a mass infinite wealth
despite playing
two games that on their own are
guaranteed
losers but is that really a paradox
when we examine the best way to flip
biased coins or spin biased roulette
wheels it just seems
like a cheap trick to manually hack a
couple of games
it's not the paradoxical situation is
that you can
alternate playing perrondo's two losing
games randomly
and it will still produce a winning one
we can use stan wagon's parando paradox
wolfram simulator to prove it
this simulator uses parando's biased
coin flip odds and allows us to set the
number of flips
and how many times we want to repeat
that experiment
parando's numbers for games a b1 and b2
are almost identical to our roulette
example so we set the number of flips in
a game and how many times we'll repeat
that game and each time we click
new run the simulator crunches those
numbers let's set this to run one
repetition of 1000 flips
when we play in a specific pattern
b-b-a-b-a
we clearly win over time but what
happens if we
choose game a and game b randomly most
of the time we win over 1 000
flips occasionally we don't that's just
variance
but when we run 2 000 simulations of 1
000
flips a pattern emerges we see a clear
upward slope despite having no plan and
no specific
hack alternating randomly between games
a
and b yields a long term win
so even if it takes a while even if it's
done
randomly by alternating between these
two
losing games we actually get a winning
result
we get to the top of the slide like our
penguins but here's the question
can you use this strategy to guarantee
that you win at a casino
no parando's paradox depends on being
able to
interact within two games and you just
can't do that in a casino
real casino games like slot machine
spins or the way roulette
is actually played are based on entirely
separate events one outcome will never
influence the outcome of the next round
or
a different game like a roulette result
will never
steer you towards an advantageous round
of
pai gow by guaranteeing that games
never intersect casinos avoid the
possibility of an exploit or
a weird parando situation the
outcome of every bedable event in a
casino depends on
nothing before it or after it it
exists in its own impenetrable bubble
that pops
as soon as that round is over and then
is blown up again
and that keeps the games fair and keeps
the casino's math
predictable the independence of each
game is
actually one of the reasons you so
rarely see new games at casinos
it's just it's just hard to come up with
games that are totally independent
give the house enough of an edge that
they win over time but also give
the player enough of a chance that they
want to play
and have fun playing what's
exciting about perrondo's paradox is not
how to win
money playing two games that no casino
would ever allow
it's figuring out how to apply its
surprising property
to other fields of study researchers are
working on real-world
applications for it in disciplines
ranging from quantum mechanics
to biogenetics and for the rest of us
it can be helpful to realize that
two losing games can become one winning
one
that in a way as weird as it sounds
two wrongs can make a right
and even what seems by all accounts
like a totally hopeless situation can
undeniably mathematically
be turned into
a winning one and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you